when you came out and you look this
place when you looked at all the people
it was that moment like it was so much
fun you know like first I'm back here
and I'm I like on my staircase right
with my big you know Versace feather yes
thing and then I walk forward and it's
like whoa it was like this is your life
from the very first beat it was electric
her entrance dazzling in a very sexy
nude colored cat suit when the crowd
beau Casper Smart
Kelly Osbourne hanging with rebel Wilson
and Justin Bieber who was singing along
with his manager 8:00 costume changes
Swarovski crystals covering the
essentials but one of the highlights
when she dedicated Lee Ann Woll max I
hope you dance to her kids
choked up tonight when you were singing
to kids you were here did you was that
in rehearsal every time I sing the damn
song I get choked up do you like the
dancers like they know me already like
everybody the band they're like she's
gonna cry again it makes me emotional to
think about them the stars were also all
there for the after-party where JLo
arrived at 1:30 in the morning but her
biggest fan this guy
she is Wonder Woman I'm telling you
between number one show save the blue
American Idol this super loving and
supportive that's more what I need than
anything else I think
you